pluie de stars dans les yvelines les
planches du département attire toujours
de grands noms de la culture en janvier
le théâtre montansier accueille alain
françon mettant en scène un ogre imbert
dans un grand théâtre russe les planches
théâtrales ont été foulés tout au long
de l'année par françois morel fanny
ardant joey starr ou encore patrick
timsit dans une adaptation d'un roman
d'albert cohen au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines génie 30 ans
avant de le jouer et là je me dis qu'au
contraire la maturité va le faire
progresser dans l'émotion dans la
simplicité dans le rien justement aller
vers le rien le non-jeu l'émotion ce pur
quoi 2018 année anniversaire pour le
cnvb le centre de musique baroque de
versailles oeuvre depuis 30 ans à la
valorisation du patrimoine musical des
xviie et xviiie siècles
il a fêté ses trois décennies au sein
même du ministère de la culture qui lie
à 20 ans il y a même encore dix ans nous
ne travaillons pas du tout de la même
manière et c'est surtout cette évolution
qui est notable
d'une part la mondialisation c'est à
dire que centre de musique baroque de
versailles aujourd'hui vraiment le
centre international de musique baroque
de versailles
et puis la deuxième chose c'est bien sûr
les nouvelles technologies le numérique
qui permettent de fonctionner de manière
totalement différent
[Musique]
de la musique populaire de la variété
française de didier gustin à christophe
willem en passant par mademoiselle k des
concerts pour toutes et tous la culture
est aussi une histoire de renouveau le
château de rambouillet a vu rouvrir les
appartements de l'empereur le château de
versailles le hameau de la reine après
trois ans de travaux
trois ans c'était aussi le temps pour
mûrir une création pris en compte pensé
par l'association vivre debout le
théâtre du sable et la compagnie black
blanc beur est présenté pour la première
fois à maurepas
[Musique]
ne dites plus la commanderie des
templiers seulement la commanderie
le lieu historique saint quentinois
change de visage une nouvelle politique
culturelle pour une nouvelle vie un fab
lab enfin une sorte d'incubateur qui va
permettre quelques expérimentations abu
d'innovation champions culturel donc
toujours dans des termes de créativité
en plus on va mettre
quelques thèmes un peu plus sur sur
l'activité
ou sur le haut sur la discipline
scientifique et technique
les nouvelles technologies deuxième vie
sur avec des nouvelles attend de nos
jeunes aussi donc c'est pour ça que vous
avez toute une ambiance
musicale
très ciblé aussi un peu de cette
population une année souvenir pour un
centenaire celui de la grande guerre le
11 novembre 1918 a fait foisonner les
esprits créatifs peinture sculpture
estampes spectacle une année de
commémoration pour ne pas oublier qu'il
ya 100 ans ce devait être la der des der